[Music]
in too far news submitted bytes slip-on
slippers house do you doing you dumb
[ __ ] there stretch man yeah I have a
friend who wears those and it's like yo
dude please don't [ __ ] wear these in
a blip yankles oh my god will give and
he's a dad of like four yeah that one
Sheba's either a hippie or a dad those
are slippers for Instagram model their
sandals interchangeable words in slip-on
slippers yes the first like that not at
least in Hawaii and they call it they
call slippers sandals sandals slippers
they just interchange those slippers
slippers a lot a lot making of us a Alon
mark a lawmaker proposed a tax for
trying on clothes in stores you [ __ ] I
hope you die clothes so if you put on
clothes you get tax for maybe because
they had to deal with so many skid marks
on thought whether they have that that
strip right like in rompers and clothes
like they have that waxed bathing suit
did you know we be honest did you know
that you can't try on underwear were you
doing it for all these years
girls don't round bro yeah but you
should still try it on over your
underwear do they give you like those
booty things that they that they use for
shoes like you know they give you those
little booty socks that you put on for
shoes but for for titties no they have
something like that right oh is that we
could pass to who don't have like
moisture and chef oh really listen
lactating thing is like [ __ ] armpits
and [ __ ] oh yeah they should do
protective cover for that too it's
literally just fat it's like a butt butt
on your chest yeah it's a butt on your
chest that's a great description of
boobs
boob slogans a butt on your chest yeah
Cosmopolitan's you do that for the cover
okay so this this lawmaker in Spain they
are the one or she's the one that's
supposing they don't use beat uh what's
it called the owner over that's why and
you're a bright no that's not the reason
so the reason why she's proposing this
because she's saying that a lot of
customers they're doing they're doing
this uh unethical practice of trying on
clothes in the brick-and-mortar store to
buy online and then go to online and buy
why is that unethical I do that all the
time
that's called shopping bro exactly her
eyes it's very anything well it's also
because like it's so hard to find that
size for something so like if you go to
a store and you go like Oh diesel I fit
diesel jeans right and then you can
write down like the type of jeans that
work out for you and instead of going
into the store all the time you can just
go online and like get the same pair I'm
too lazy for that I just order it online
and if it doesn't fit I return it to the
brick-and-mortar so you know what ends
up happening is I never return it and I
I'm past a date and I just have stacks
of clean so you have enough time to go
to the store trying to conceive it go
back home or it online but you don't
have time to just return it I don't know
why Amazon is brilliant cuz everyone's
been for years like why does an Amazon
open brick-and-mortar stores and the
answer is because Best Buy [ __ ]
exists everyone just goes the Best Buy
they look at all the Amazon [ __ ] they
want there and they go by on [ __ ]
Amazon pay for that [ __ ] they don't need
to Best Buy our saps dude you're saps
I bring my phone with a price check that
[ __ ] exactly you know what's kind of the
equivalent of an Amazon brick-and-mortar
it's Costco though you get it like
similar prices you do pay membership but
get similar prices you get to look
around they have a variety of things I
don't we sneak it oh no yeah when you
checkout your [ __ ] when you checkout
they got it they got it figured no not
if you pay cash
oh really wait actually I don't know no
you have to show your card you have to
be four pin cash no you have to show
your company's Costco
just reactionary solving okay castles
not that good though unless like you
have big family yeah clothes Costco is
the worst version of target because you
go in there not knowing what you're yeah
because they always got dope [ __ ] at
Costco to like they had this like that's
going but I still pay for my man what
the [ __ ] do I need 30 peaches for god
damnit I still love it you know why cuz
I want the [ __ ] deal my good is like
cuz my grandparents raised us with like
like because they came from the Great
Depression so I always feel like I need
to have enough [ __ ] so like whenever I
see a deal for the bigger panthous of
stuff I always buy it don't I know that
my wife's eternal suffering
there were nowhere to put any of this
stuff so we just line the walls with it
oh no no frustrating I I think I'm gonna
go back to being cheap cuz it was more
fun like to find the deal and it feels
like you you're in oh you should try
couponing you would kill it cause you
always zone into your hobbies mm-hmm
[ __ ] you would literally get actually
get money back yeah you be the guy
getting $300 back from the grocery store
and they're like I don't even know how
you figured I'd be the person behind you
just trying to slash their [ __ ] tires
afternoon [ __ ] [ __ ] I've been here
for an hour
I'd be like those people that they
[ __ ] hey it's that guy again did you
all see that that [ __ ] on TV where the
lady just literally has a binder full of
coupons yeah nice to the [ __ ] T for
every single time you take it back is
that nobody here's the thing is that
like you're saving let's say you save
five dollars but it took you two hours
to say that five dollars that's time is
money what did you really save that turn
on daytime television yeah they have a
system and then like some of their kids
are old enough now are like just the
shows that I watch it's it's like it
seems like they only spend like an hour
combing through things and then they
sort it all together and then like when
they mix and match and then they have a
routine so then once they get to that
point I think they're not all this way
but the ones that do it successfully
they have they
they attack it like it's a business
guaranteed over for themselves either
they end up reselling it on Amazon yeah
so they make money I'm saying when you
it's like who has the time
Nikki hottie ass Nicky over here extra
belay I just don't want to deal with
people who are saving and making a [ __ ]
ton of money off of the [ __ ] that's the
answer not making a [ __ ] ton of money
because they're out instead of spending
their time working and making one either
about their job recession Amazon eBay
the cutout that's the carve out is if
your sell out everyone's reso eating an
ROI
I'll put it like this I'm so [ __ ]
bougie I'll have the coupon I'll tear it
on their face like that because you
[Laughter]
don't need money I know people like it's
not Extreme Couponing but they'll get
the coupons in they get like 30 $40 off
their [ __ ] thing and I'm like [ __ ]
are these coupons that dude I feel like
Bed Bath & Beyond and Michaels are the
two places but you could just like look
up Michaels or bread breath down really
quick and grab a cab there's a whole
bunch of coupon RetailMeNot whatever
they have a shit's in a coupon there
yeah there's just websites to I remember
slick deals was so dope yeah like I
don't know about now but then I remember
there was a time when it was really dope
like like not a lot of people knew about
it will still Groupon or is that dead no
Groupon still go we did a bunch of
Groupon she did a wife wiki bye
and honey I use honey yeah save you
bunny I'm online shopping what the week
you buy this is same thing as honey pie
yeah they find every single coupon code
that you can be automatically my [ __ ] is
I just I'm out of the grocery store I
looked out of the tag and I see the
price per [ __ ] ounce yeah you
can get deals no yeah if you look at the
price per ounce you're you're always
getting a better deal if you get the
more on one that's what happens with
Costco that's why you get dirty [ __ ]
peaches because they're like 80 cents
apiece versus a dollar something but
sometimes you can and they're better
they can you spend more like I do that
all you can eat all the peaches every
[ __ ] peaches all that diary a lot of
diarrhea how does that fall for 30 days
30 days for 60 features go into the
market by like ready to buy some soy
milk but leave with 10 other items cuz
it's on sale so I actually end up
spending more yeah why don't I only do
the right thing you look at my fridge
right now there's a bunch of peaches in
there I love a chilled peach guy say I
respect that I love a chilled peach not
a room temp eat I hate that [ __ ] yeah do
you have a fruit basket I do
what are you put in there though I put
oranges and bananas and pecos garlic ya
know some growing roots
Browdy my girls you did not the food
Casey feels into food oh wow that's for
the public in the fridge yeah if you do
and you're not supposed to do it it's a
baby alien girls ruin 3 weeks of being
in the fresh garlic I grew up like super
fast I've had that happen to me
usually onions banana
we have my names in the fridge - I need
some potatoes you leave outside well if
you cut it you could saran wrap it and
put it in the fridge but it dries out or
something
yeah potatoes - potatoes - but I put the
potatoes in the fridge now because they
were getting mold in the cabinet and
then if you get like Wolvie potatoes
it's like poison kill yourself of that
[ __ ] so they make you die from smelling
it if you get a rotted potato enough
rotted and they would hail it yeah yeah
I don't think so I had a sucker like six
month old potatoes one time moated on my
floor right did you with it and did you
pick an idea yeah I didn't really have a
smell well you got very lucky commodious
[ __ ] you got very lucky people were like
I don't get it I've combined pneumonia
with chlorine and I was Milania or what
is it ammonia with what is it bleach I
don't know some something like that
otherwise you're like it starts burning
know you like past happen to Gina she
was telling us that some she was here
that herd cleaner her house cleaner she
ended up mixing what was it like a kind
of spray and wood bleach or some comment
comment one of us and she ended up
having to leave in like Yuma gave you
the whole place that's what I'm saying
so yeah maybe you got away with one ant
yep just like to say she did like but
this listen potato has to be bad enough
that it's like liquid yes yeah on my
floor is [ __ ] liquid mode thanks a
bragging about how shitty is house
there's like [ __ ] it this much mole of
my for like six months
run
man was in the middle putting potatoes
have to put on [ __ ] glasses just walk
into my own cat [ __ ] bro
he's like it always finite live yeah
good good for you and that's crazy man
Christina by the way you're lucky woman
oh my she live
[Laughter]
[Music]